[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 4 mars bienvenue
dans ce premier set 8 journal du mois
sur tv 78 très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale tout de suite les titres de cette
édition c'est l'assemblée délibérante du
territoire le conseil départemental des
yvelines a plusieurs missions et
compétences et le dossier de la semaine
focus ce soir sur les investissements en
matière de transport premier poste de
dépense pour la collectivité
[Musique]
le collectif est né dans le sillage de
la contestation des gilets jaunes et
stylo rouge regroupe des professeurs en
colère non content des conditions de
travail et d'apprentissage ils demandent
notamment et des engagements du
gouvernement avant le 15 avril deux de
ses membres sont avec nous en plateau
emilie 16-10 et anne serre et enfin neuf
auteurs de romans fatah fantastiques ou
encore de polars tous présents pour une
séance de dédicace ses représentants de
la ligue de l'imaginaire était samedi au
magasin cultura aux clayes sous bois et
les lecteurs étaient au rendez vous
invite également dans ce journal l'école
3 i/s qui vient de fêter dix ans de
partenariat avec l'académie des césar
est à suivre tout à l'heure l es
résultats sport yvelinois du week end là
mais avant de développer ces titres
depuis 18h les yvelines sont plus placés
en vie en vigilance orange aux vents
violents météo france avait émis une
alerte pour le département avec le
passage de la tempête freya des rafales
de 110 et jusqu'à 120 km heure ont été
recensées occasionnant quelques dégâts
et jusqu'à 5000 300 foyers yvelines ont
été privés d'électricité 7 me au plus
fort de la tempête
ce matin encore 160 clients étaient
concernés les équipes d'aînés disent
mobilisés toute la journée pour un
retour à la normale est des
interventions notamment dans le sud
yvelines et dans le mantois
premier volet de notre dossier mensuel
il est consacré cette semaine à l'action
du département des yvelines quelles sont
ses missions quelles sont ses
compétences nous allons vous aider à y
voir plus clair le reportage de ce soir
revient sur le travail mené par la
collectivité sur les infrastructures en
termes de transports patrick jacques de
dixmude et où ils friedrich avec 114
millions d'euros inscrits au budget 2010
uytsel les routes et les transports
représentent le plus important poste de
dépenses en matière d'investissement
pour le département des yvelines
car en marge de l'entretien de près de
1600 km de route il faut également
penser à l'avenir et donc modifier
certains équipements en fonction des
besoins des usagers
exemple ici avec l'aménagement et
l'élargissement de la rd 30 à plaisir
lancer en 2015 entre création de
giratoires et construction de ponts ou
encore ici entre montesson et
sartrouville avec la réalisation de
voies nouvelles
les routes départementales sont
complètement saturé dans cette région
notamment en centre urbain et qu'il
était bon de pouvoir dévier la
circulation de transit sur un nouvel axe
de circulation qui est la départementale
121 et d'autres projets sont en cours
comme sur la rd 154 avec le
contournement de verneuil-sur-seine et
vernouillet toujours dans le cadre de
ses compétences telles que définies par
la nouvelle organisation territoriale de
2015 le département intervient également
pour développer les transports en commun
avec la création d'une voie de bus
spécifique lors du doublement du pont
schuller à la verrière il ne faut pas
oublier le transport ferroviaire
plusieurs dossiers importants sont en
cours en partenariat avec l'état et la
région
la ligne 18 du métro automatique du
grand paris express est aussi le
prolongement du rer e à l'ouest c'est au
tour de table
on ne participe pas des travaux ne
peuvent pas se réaliser
je pense à eole
concerne la vallée de seine
mais je pense aussi aux trams 13 qui va
relier un jour versailles mais
commençons par saint cyr l'école jusqu'à
saint germain en laye et qui se
poursuivra jusqu à poissy et les enjeux
sont importants car le cadre de vie des
habitants et l'attractivité du
territoire sont en jeu une entreprise
viendra sur un territoire qui est
attractif
donc il faut qu'il ait le foncier et il
faut qu'il ait les organes
d'infrastructures qui lui permettent de
faire venir ses salariés de pouvoir
faire venir ses fournisseurs et de
pouvoir livrer dans de bonnes conditions
sa production on notera que le
département a lancé en 2018 un
observatoire de la mobilité afin de
mesurer au mieux les besoins
il a révélé l'an dernier que les
yvelinois se déplacer en moyenne plus
que les autres franciliens et que 54 %
de ces déplacements se faisaient en
voiture contre 38 % à l'échelle
régionale
six mois de prison avec sursis une mise
à l'épreuve verdict du tribunal de paris
à l'encontre des de l'auteur des tags
antisémites sur le rer c il a été pris
en flagrant délit mercredi dernier en
gare de versailles rive gauche
l'individu serait un fonctionnaire du
conseil départemental des yvelines âgé
de 65 ans il a avoué être à l'origine
d'une cinquantaine de taguer injures sur
le rer c pour le moment elle la justice
n'a pas tranché sur le caractère
antisémite du tas qui fait l'objet d'une
autre procédure
premier invité avec moi en plateau
première invitée même puisque ce sont
des femmes et lee et milliers à 16,10 et
anne serre et bonsoir tout les deux
professeurs membres des stylos rouges de
l'académie de versailles le collectif de
professeurs qui sont en colère alors
vous avez envoyé récemment une lettre
ouverte adressée au président de la
république au premier ministre ainsi
qu'aux ministres de l'éducation
nationale que vous sommé de prendre
plusieurs engagements sur des sujets que
l'on va évoquer dans un instant et vous
avez également alerté les sénateurs
récemment sur le projet pour une école
de la confiance qui va être discutée
prochainement en séance au sénat on va
parler de ses actualités dans un instant
déjà ce mouvement des stylos rouges
comment est il né dans quel contexte est
inné qui compte aujourd'hui soixante dix
mille membres dans toute la france
exactement 2300 un peu plus de 2300 dans
l'académie de versailles qui regroupe
des professeurs des écoles des collèges
des lycées et des lycées professionnels
et par ce mot par ce mouvement qui est
né sur les réseaux sociaux
nous voilà nous réfléchissons ensemble
comment réfléchir aux mesures qui sont
annoncées par le gouvernement et qui
nous déplaisent énormément parce que
nous considérons que l'école est
vraiment en danger
1 je rappelle que nous sommes vraiment
très attaché aux valeurs de l'école
publique laïque et gratuite et
républicaine nous sommes des gens de
terrain nous savons de quoi nous parlons
et nous avons envie que notre expérience
voilà donc soit mise après soit mise à
profit pour élaborer un texte fort et
les projets de loi on vous consulte pas
assez aujourd'hui pour élaborer ses
textes tout à fait et on est obligé de
d'agir ainsi effectivement pour faire
entendre nos devoirs et ce mouvement des
stylos rouges et ce qui là aussi une
volonté de se placer en dehors des
syndicats qui sont la voie
traditionnelle d'habitude pour pour
contester des projets loin
personnellement je ne suis pas syndiqué
je n'ai jamais fait de politique mais
c'est simplement en tant que voix la
professeure de terrain qui a droit au
chapitre il me semble je suis aussi
citoyenne et j'ai mon mot à dire par
rapport à ma profession qu'on est en
train de mettre à mal énormément et des
valeurs qui me qui m'anime dans mon
métier sont vraiment en danger
aujourd'hui mais qu'est ce que c'est
être professeur aujourd'hui quels sont
vos conditions de travail
c'est pour ça qu'on a envoyé des lettres
j'ai souvent aux sénateurs voilà parce
que comme a dit ma collègue l'école l
affaire de tous les citoyens et je pense
que bah tu vas me paraît en fait on
demande que l'état soit bienveillant
envers ses personnels et c'est anne qui
a plutôt est bien développé ce point là
et moi je développerai après la
bienveillance de l'état envers ses
élèves certainement juste avant de
développer ces points on parlait déjà
parlé il ya un instant des actions que
vous avez menées notamment cette lettre
ouverte envoyée au président de la
république au premier ministre et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale c'est
une sorte d'ultimatum justement sur
cette thématique quelles sont-elles
aujourd'hui les thématiques prioritaires
pour vous pour réformer peut-être
l'éducation à votre avis qui ce qu'on
demande nous tout simplement c'est
vraiment une école qui soit beaucoup
plus humaine et bienveillante envers ses
personnels comme envers ses élèves
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui nous
avons vraiment la volonté de faire du
bon travail
on est vraiment attachés à notre métier
on aime profondément notre métier mais
on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de choses nous empêchent de
fonctionner correctement et de vraiment
réaliser notre mission qui est vraiment
la transmission de connaissances dont
culture de préparer au mieux les jeunes
à leur avenir et au quotidien on
al'impression vraiment de batailler pour
pourra avancer tout simplement et notre
institution en fait ne nous permet pas
toujours de réaliser ce que nous
aimerions profondément faire il ya des
tas de choses qu'on nous demande de
faire qui alourdissent notre tâche
première qui est vraiment centré sur la
pédagogie avant tout mais voilà on court
toujours après le temps nous demande de
faire de plus en plus de tâches
administratives qui alourdissent nous
journée qui sont très longues qui sont
chargés en réunion qui sont chargés en
tâches multiples avec beaucoup de
dossiers administratifs a réalisé il ya
des tas de nouvelles choses qu'on nous
demande de réaliser au détriment des
élèves se dégradent vos conditions de
travail aussi les conditions
d'apprentissage pour les élèves c'est
des deux côtés que vous dénoncez souvent
alors au niveau de la dégradation
effectivement des conditions de travail
on constate une précarisation du métier
d'enseignant énormément avec énormément
de professeurs contractuels de plus en
plus maintenant avec un statut vraiment
très difficile parce que par exemple
pendant les vacances scolaires ils ne
sont pas ils ne sont pas rémunérés 1
alors qu'ils étaient avant depuis peu ce
n'est plus le cas on a aussi le problème
des des auxiliaires de vie scolaire qui
sont payés vraiment au four 20 ans en
fait donc c'est pas il n'y a pas la
reconnaissance et notre des métiers
l'éducation nationale et dans notre
groupe de 6 le rouge
il ya aussi tous ces métiers là les
avait
les principaux ça envoie vraiment de
l'éducation nation alors l'un des
combats actuels pour les stylos rouges
c'est ce projet de loi pour une école de
la confiance qui a été adopté par les
députés qui va être examiné par les
sénateurs les objectifs en tout cas
affiché par l'éducation nationale c'est
d'élever le niveau général des élèves
plus et de justice sociale également au
travers de l'école est la loi prévoit
notamment d'abaisser l'instruction
obligatoire de six à trois ans confié
certaines missions d'enseignement aux
surveillants également de favoriser les
expérimentations pédagogiques il ya
beaucoup de choses au programme de ce
projet de loi vous avez envoyé une
lettre au sénateur pourquoi choisir les
sénateurs pourquoi alerté finalement ces
sénateurs qui n'ont pas le mot final sur
sur la loi qui n'ont pas le le dernier
mot en fait parce qu on est tous des
citoyens on a tous le droit de dire ce
que l'on pense pour notre et pour notre
école républicaine et citoyenne et le
texte en fait va passer là au sénat pour
une relecture et bar va passer après aux
assemblées nationales donc on continue
aussi à rencontrer les députés sur le
sur le forme le texte est très vendeur
voilà sauf que actuellement il ya plus à
ses preuves parce que voilà comment
d'une relation salariale que au niveau
de la maternelle avec cette instruction
à trois ans dont vous parlez ben en fait
c'est annoncé mais on voit pas les
impacts sur le terrain comment cela
pourra être fait il y aura c'est trop
flou il va y avoir une augmentation des
charges territoriales il ya actuellement
il ya aussi rien qui est fait pour
accueillir toute cette masse d'élèves
qui rentrait chez chez eux dormir et que
l'on doit retourner à l'école alors
aussi de la transition écologique c'est
à dire que en petite session
les parents vont devoir faire deux fois
plus de trajets avec cette construction
aussi à trois ans le postulat de départ
de dire il faut relever le niveau des
élèves il faut plus de justice sociale
et le bon mais
complètement en plus avec cette mesure
il y avait l'expérimentation fait déjà
des jardins d'enfants qui ont pouvoir
scolariser les élèves jusqu'à 6 ans
c'est à dire que j'attends un enfant il
faut être soit privé soit aux charges
encore des communes et donc à terme nous
on se pose la question est-ce que c'est
pas la disparition de la maternelle
publique avec des enseignants étaient
pour enseigner via des jardins d'enfants
communaux ou privés avec par exemple des
atsem qui vont enseigner puisque le
statut donc de ses agences spécialisées
de l'école maternelle a changé en 2018
et à peuvent avoir des missions
d'enseignement d'art est bien trop bas
actuels je suis désolé on arrive déjà la
fin de cet entretien juste pour savoir
s'il ya d'autres mobilisations prévues
alors cette lettre envoyée
qu'est ce que vous prévoyez de bruz
mobilisation contre aussi à
l'établissement public de savoir qu'on
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire la ligue le
regroupement de la maternelle
élémentaire et collège sur la même
entité
il ya des combats aussi sur l'accès à
l'université où les étudiants étrangers
hors union européenne voient leurs frais
de scolarité augmenter de mille pour
cent sûr aussi le lycée avec ses actions
de 20 sur 20 ou les professeurs garde
les notes des élèves c'est juste pour
bloquer parcours sup
parce que actuellement n'y aura plus un
bac nationale y aura un bac locale
puisque tous les lycées vont pas pouvoir
présenter toutes les spécialités donc va
y avoir une prédestination compris ya
plusieurs sujets aujourd'hui donc aux
problèmes sur les terres
et sur ces sujets locaux et dernier
peut-être et le rassemblement du 17 mars
je voudrais simplement dire que déjà nos
conditions de travail sont déjà très
difficile actuellement
voilà se dégrade de plus en plus avec
des élèves de plus en plus nombreux par
classe et cette loi va contribuer
énormément à vraiment dégrader encore
plus notre travail ne s'empêchait
vraiment de fonctionner au mieux
merci à sa merci emilie 16-10 d'être
passé sur ce plateau professeurs et
membres des stylos rouges pour
l'académie de versailles tombé de rideau
pour le salon de l'agriculture il s'est
achevé hier à paris avec une
fréquentation en légère baisse cette
année bilan plus positif côté local avec
plus de 25 exposants de la région ile de
france présents sur place un stand
commun notamment entre les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine les produits
yvelinois ont eu du succès pas moins de
huit médailles obtenues dans le concours
général agricole médaille d'argent pour
le yaourt y d'évaluer le roi que vous
voyez à l'image trois médailles d'argent
pour les yaourts de la ferme de viltain
à jouy en josas et surtout une médaille
d'or pour un yaourt encore un autre
yaourt celui au lait de vaches de la
ferme de à grignon les passionnés de
polars ont pu rencontrer samedi après
midi neuf auteurs issus de la ligue de
l'imaginaire ce collectif créé en 2008 a
pour objectif de défendre cette
littérature dite populaire et les
lecteurs au rendez vous ont pu repartir
avec leur photo souvenir et leurs
dédicaces le reportage d'aurélie ans il
y avait foule pour cette séance de
dédicaces xxl neuf auteurs se sont
prêtés au jeu des signatures auprès de
leurs lecteurs dans ce magasin culturel
des clayes-sous-bois leur point commun
ils ont tous écrit des best-sellers des
polars pour la plupart ils font
également tous partie de la ligue de
l'imaginaire un collectif lancée en 2008
pour défendre la littérature de
l'imaginaire vraiment autour de ce style
littéraire parce que trop souvent on
nous parle de littérature blanche et du
reste de la littérature comme si le
reste de la littérature n'était pas
importante une littérature qui plaît à
en juger par cette file d'attenté qui
s'allongent et de minute en minute
il fallait en effet être patient pour
prendre la pose aux côtés de son auteur
préféré
ou bien pour obtenir le précieux sésame
la dédicace personnalisée très un prêt
donner c'est toujours quand on passe du
virtuel au réel c'est toujours
impressionnant mais voilà je suis
contente
bon bah on a vu le groupe id base quoi
on lui a dit premier dit qu'on adorait
ce qu'il écrivait rien de très original
alors on aimerait médias quelque chose
d'original n'en trouve pas parce que
quand on sait ce qu il écrit dans ce
décor on sera pas à la hauteur quoi
composé de cinq écrivains à sa création
la ligue de l'imaginaire compte
aujourd'hui vingt membres
plus qu'un collectif c'est une véritable
bande d'amis qui aiment se retrouver
plusieurs fois dans l'année on se limite
tuellement pour certains parfois quand
il y en a qui trouvent pas une idée
titre ont fait des brainstormings
ensemble et on compare nos expériences
on aime se retrouver mon âme aussi a
justement aller dans des des salons dans
des librairies dans des médiathèques
pour justement parler littérature
mission réussie ce samedi après midi
pour la ligue de l'imaginaire les
lecteurs friands de ce genre littéraire
ont été plus de 200 avoir fait le
déplacement
cet événement culturel est l'un des
rendez vous phares du début d'année la
44e cérémonie des césar s'est déroulée
le 22 février c'était à la salle pleyel
à paris et dans l'équipe technique de
cet événement des étudiants de 3e
l'institut international de l'image et
du son basé à elancourt qu'ils ont
réalisées et des captations sur place
pour en parler sur ce plateau deux
invités stéphane lamy bonsoir pour soi
vous êtes le directeur pédagogique de
troisième
c'est léa charniers bonsoir étudiants
33e année réalisation audiovisuelle et
vous avez participé à cette cérémonie
des césars troisième qui a fêté cette
année stéphane lamy dix ans de
collaboration avec l'académie à des arts
et techniques du cinéma qui organise
cette cérémonie c'est un anniversaire
important on imagine c'est important
pour nous parce qu'on a commencé ce
partenariat simplement avec des des
master class et puis petit à petit
notre travail a été reconnue par
l'académie donc on a couvert de plus en
plus d'événements pour les césar jusqu'à
arriver à faire des aussi des plateaux
des captations pendant jusqu'à la
cérémonie de pouvoir y placer des
étudiants sur cette cérémonie c'est une
fierté pour l'école c'est en tout cas un
partenariat qui a évolué vous l'avez
this a évolué c'est une fierté parce que
ma part on vous fait confiance donc ça
prouve quand même que nos étudiants font
du travail de qualité et puis pour nous
c'est très très important justement des
maîtres en situation à l'extérieur
là on répond à une commande
professionnelle en plus on est devant un
très joli parterre de profession ce qui
peut être aussi assez stressant pour les
étudiants et c'est vrai que c'est on y
mettre des réelles conditions de
production et donc ça s'est assis
remplaçable dont bien sûr on les en
garde on est avec eux mais c'est un
dispositif qu'on ne peut pas reproduire
dans une école et qui amène la théorie
finalement l'école et là on peut
appliquer tout ce savoir la dimension
plus globalement partenariale de
troisième
si un axe primordial pour l'école de
pouvoir collaborer avec d'autres vivent
pas ce qu'il faut comment parler juste
avant il faut que les étudiants soient
mis dans des situations réelles non bien
sûr dans notre école ont fait que ce
soit pour la filière cinéma la filière
sont l'animation le jeu vidéo où le
spectacle vivant on essaie de d'inclure
systématiquement dans la pédagogie des
rencontres comme cela alors le
effectivement le partenaire le plus
célèbre c'est celui des césars parce que
ça fait maintenant dix ans que vous en
parliez
on a aussi la cérémonie des lumières par
exemple l'équivalent des golden globes
américains que l'on organise cette fois
totalement nous que l'on a fait ou début
février
donc là on avait à peu près 80 étudiants
sur le terrain avec une
presque une vingtaine d'intervenants
donc c'est un événement très important
on les a fait participer aussi alors là
plus pour l'animation voir le design a
partagé avec tf1 games par exemple là
cette année on a un partenariat entre
notre nos scénaristes de ski sont
spécialisation scénario du cinéma
audiovisuel avec la sorbonne par exemple
où il travaille sur du game design donc
des concepts de jeux vidéo mais
plusieurs occasions pouvoir occasion
voilà et on n'est jamais aussi ses
connaissances sur scène par exemple à
mantes-la-jolie qu'un festival de blues
ou là on a plutôt les équipes du
spectacle vivant les équipes sont les
équipes lumière qui vont voir grossir
les rangs des équipes et voilà les
situations réelles sont irremplaçables
et ça les rend plus autonome pour la
suite en lea va peut-être nous confirmer
tout ça racontez nous un peu comment
s'est déroulée cette soirée des césar
pour vous qu'avez vous fait pendant
cette soirée a commencé tôt le matin
vers 9 heures on est arrivé donc on a dû
préparer tout le matériel etc
c'était c'est assez intense mais c'était
sympa et alors après on a été répartie
un peu tous les côtés nous en avait qui
étaient sur le tapis rouge d'autres qui
étaient dans la salle
là où il va avoir les prix on avait
d'autres qui étaient
au niveau du cou tel moi j'étais au
cocktail donc on a ce qui arrive en fait
après le tapis rouge donc ils vont
manger là le but c'est d'essayer de pas
justement les prendre en train de manger
ni boire et c'est d'avoir des sourires
des rires des retrouvailles
donc ça c'était assez intéressant
justement et puis on se rend compte que
c'est pas facile justement d'avoir ces
moments qui sont alors on les a pas tout
le temps c'est live comme on appelle
membres avons c'est vraiment c'est mon
intervention que c'est donc là on
apprend beaucoup et ensuite on avait
pendant la cérémonie du coup après tout
ce qu'ils avaient des primes on les
recevait est donc là on avait des
interviews et donc la phalecque on
prépare notre plateau notre plateau et
puis après c'était mieux en direct sur
facebook donc là on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur donc là aussi c'est intéressant
c'est andrés oui oui mais sans fin pour
moi c'est un bon stress mais voilà après
il y en a d'autres systèmes - moi j'aime
bien ce serait cela du du direct et
justement on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
et c'est ça qui est intéressant et vous
diriez en quoi cette expérience a été
enrichissante
vous qui êtes en 3e année réalisation
audiovisuelle ça vous apporte quoi dans
ce parcours
cette expérience bah en fait on va on
est vraiment bien on est plongé dans
dans le vrai donc on a pas on sait pas
un exercice soit à l'école qu'on fait ou
on nous dit bon bah c'est pas grave on
va on va retravailler derrière on l'a on
est vraiment dans notre milieu dont pour
moi c'est ma passion donc j'avais du
plaisir à être là c'est c'est jeu
c'était une expérience
je pense que je souhaite aux futurs
élèves qui seront à 3 est ce parce qu'on
apprend en fait on s'est lancé un
cerveau moment ça va vous servir pour la
suite de votre parcours ans et oui et la
suite là vous êtes en 3e année c'est la
fin bientôt des effets pour vous on a un
stage de fin d'année de six mois et donc
là après fo ont fait un peu on a envie
moi ça serait plus dans le cinéma et la
télé alors j'aime les deux milieux qui
sont pas trop voilà après c'est espérer
d'être pris dans sur le lieu de notre
stage et d'être gardé après sur un court
métrage sur une salle et pouvoir
travailler continuer avec l'équipe
au delà du sage en fait cette pleine
réussite on arrive déjà la fin de cet
entretien en tout cas pour toutes les
informations sur 3ds
je parle sous votre contrôle stéphane
lamy où on peut retrouver bien sûr
toutes ces formations sur le site de
troisième qui s'est affichée en bas de
cet écran merci à vous deux est d'être
passé sur ce plateau et peut être qu'on
reparlera d'autres événements couverts
par les étudiants de 3e en ces vacances
d'hiver de nombreuses activités pourquoi
pas une sortie à culturel à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines la maison elsa
triolet aragon propose une exposition
jusqu'au 12 mai consacré à pierre marie
lejeune et niki de saint phalle des
oeuvres personnelles et contemporaine de
pierre marie lejeune mêlant dessins
collages et peintures à mais aussi des
travaux croisé issu de la collaboration
avec niki de saint phalle décédé en 2002
présentation au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude la collaboration de pierre
marie lejeune et de niki de saint phalle
elle a duré plus de vingt ans thiam
arrivé jeune avait travaillé en tant
qu'assistante bien de niki de saint
phalle sur des grands projets comme la
fontaine stravinsky à paris ou le jardin
et toscane qui tenait à coeur à niki de
saint phalle et envers 1999 il avait
réalisé quelques oeuvres ensemble aussi
l niki de saint phalle aimait beaucoup
réaliser des oeuvres à 80 exposition
ouverte jusqu'au 12 mai au tarif de 4
euros
[Musique]
et pour le retour du journal en formule
26 minutes le retour aussi de la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euro bonds soir dans ça rigole
l'actualité de revenir sur ce plateau
c'est un plaisir galons pour moi alors
l'actualité sportive du week-end en tout
cas les principaux résultats que vous
allez nous commenter avec notamment du
handball féminin pour commencer
direction le championnat de nationale 2
montigny le bretonneux n'a pas réussi à
créer l'exploit à domicile ce samedi
soir face au quatrième du classement tôt
le carantec
le résumé du match à des images
d'aurélie ronces avantage de zellige à
l'entraîneur de montigny le bretonneux
peut se prendre la tête à deux mains ces
jeunes ne sont pas passés loin de
l'exploit contre thau carantec timide en
début de match les inhumant ten se font
bousculer à domicile et perdent
logiquement 17 à 14
à la mi-temps on a eu du mal déjà dans
un premier temps à s'adapter à une set
zéro c'est à dire que ils ont fait
sortir systématiquement leur gardienne
de but pour pouvoir attaquer avec une
joueuse supplémentaire donc
on a mon après beaucoup de buts dans
cette situation là laisse monti le
bretonneux rectifie le tir en début de
seconde période et arrive à repasser
devant 21 à 20 à moins de 20 minutes de
la fin du match mais ce sont finalement
les joueuses de tous le carantec qui
s'imposent 30 à 26 lors de cette 14ème
journée de nationale 2 tous quand même
que on a bien joué mais malheureusement
il ya toujours un gagnant et un perdant
mon analyse c'est vrai que on a
énormément été en échec face à la
gardienne de but on a trouvé des
solutions de tir mais on était aussi en
échec je pense que c'est surtout par
rapport à ça que l'on perd le match
après cette défaite montigny le
bretonneux plantes en milieu de tableau
à la 7e place du classement
la montée étant compromise le staff
travaillerait déjà sur la saison
prochaine toujours handball mais cette
fois ci chez les garçons plaisir s'est
imposé ce dimanche face à saint michel
ce sport lors de la 13e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 les plaisirs
on a longtemps porté 23 à 21 ans
classement cette victoire leur permet de
rester en dehors de la zone de
relégation à la 9e place avec un bilan
de 4 victoires pour 9 défaites depuis le
début de la saison on continue par du
football américain et le championnat de
deuxième division casque d'or les temps
qui devait prouver que la défaite contre
les vikings n'était qu'une erreur de
parcours les élans courtois sont donc
entrer rapidement dans la partie face
aux gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie avec
deux touchdowns inscrits en avantage que
les tant pis on gérait tout au long de
la partie les templiers l'emportent
finalement sur le score de 20 à 14 on
écoute la réaction de l'un des
entraîneurs
c'était une belle équipe en face qui
nous a posé quelques problèmes
on aurait pu se mettre à l'abri beaucoup
plus rapidement mais en face à une belle
équipe et maintenant c'est à nous tous à
nous d'élever le niveau maintenant avec
cette victoire les templiers d'elancourt
reste leader de la conférence nord de 2e
division à quatre victoires en cinq
matches disputés
des résultats qui permettent d'espérer
des playoffs en fin de saison une
possible montée en première division
on est là pour gagner tous les matches
et si on gagne tous les matches on est
champion en fin de l'année donc le même
objectif c'est toujours la même chose
et là pour gagner le prochain match on
va gagner aussi on va travailler on a un
mois pour bien bosser et ça va le faire
prochain match pour les templiers le
samedi 30 mars à domicile contre les
dragons de paris est un mot rapide pour
terminer michael il y avait là les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste
alors la france est revenue avec cinq
médailles des championnats du monde qui
se sont déroulés en pologne la semaine
dernière mention spéciale à quentin
lafargue le pistard licencié au vélo
club elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
a raflé l'or sur l'épreuve du kilomètre
son premier titre mondial après le
bronze en 2016 l'argent en 2017
il va maintenant prendre des vacances
bien méritées avant de revenir au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lui donne toutes nos félicitations merci
michael dans un instant le 7-8 fort pour
revenir sur l'ensemble de l'actualité
sportive du week-end c'est la fin de ce
journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]